we all in this world we need to keep
talking and we need to keep talking
about the things that are important not
the shallow but the deep was Lady Gaga
is talking about things that are
important she's defending cardi B's
Grammy win after the rapper got a whole
lot of backlash I remember last year
when I could have won for bordick yeah
Lloyd was a party cos not party with a
guy [ __ ] now this year's a problem
mother monster took to Twitter on
Tuesday night posting of this pic of the
pair at the awards show and writing
quote it is so hard to be a woman in
this industry what it takes how hard we
work through the disrespectful
challenges just to make art I love you
cardi you deserve your Awards let's
celebrate her fight lift her up and
honor her she is brave no surprise right
after Gaga tweeted that fans went nuts
begging for the pair to collaborate and
can I just say I am fully on board for
that to happen Gaga's obviously a fan of
cardies cardi has yet to respond but
when I chatted with her a couple months
ago she actually talked about the
importance of women supporting women in
this industry
it feels really amazing you know a lot
of people be thinking like it's supposed
to be like a caddy thing and it just
feels good like when other women show
love to each other and they don't know
how much like that means samito like
that that means that yo you know what
one day you need a kidney I might give
you mines and I barely drink so they
might be mines might be good is that
what kind of woman you are
yeah I love that I want to be friends
with cardi B yes I look out for people
and obviously gagas all about that too
I've been a part of the Grammy community
for ten years now and just to be here to
celebrate all these beautiful artists is
wonderful and
just happy for everyone unfortunately
cardi is taking the backlash pretty hard
she went on an expletive filled rant on
Instagram after the haters came for her
and a sense deleted her account it's not
my style for people to put other people
down to uplift somebody else that's not
my style and that's not what I'm ripped
and I don't support that however I've
been taking a lot of today I'm seeing a
book today and I saw a lot last night
and I'm sick of this I work hard for my
boo and it didn't stop there yikes my
lutes I'm platinum on and every chart
that it was Marvel was always top ten
number one album as well as of now
cardis Instagram is still deactivated
and I'm sad about it but she does have
Twitter's and Gaga is not the only one
who has her back
Lil Kim salt and pepper Pusha T and Remy
Ma all tweeted their excitement for
cardis wins of course we know offset has
been a big support to the on-again
couple showed up to the Grammys together
and he went on stage with her when she
won you husband Thank You nastiest
because he was that oh you won't do this
Alba girl we go have this baby are we
gonna make this album but back to Gaga
and cardi I'm serious how do we make
this collab happen of course we'll have
all the latest cardi news for you so be
sure to subscribe to all things et until
next time I am Katie underscore Kraus
and bye for now
[Music]